could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i had to achieve i had to be perfect i
guess ultimately take on the suffering
the player of the tournament johnny
wilkinson a genuine
sporting legend how much pressure has
this man been under this week for me it
was do or die on the field so therefore
where other people kind of called it
quits and threw in the towel i didn't
have the
choice this will go down in history was
your mental health better or worse after
that moment when i was on the field in
the zone i was operating at a level i
couldn't even understand
waking up the next morning you know
leaves you in the cold light of day i
thought there was going to be joy here i
was convinced there isn't
i spent my life
being very fit but not really that
healthy
health is about what fitness can come
out of unless you look after health it's
dangerous
people say i wish i'd made more of my
life wish i'd enjoyed every moment but
that starts with health working on
someone else really doesn't work for
anyone working on yourself tends to work
for everyone
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
johnny
um you went on to become one of the real
greats in rugby and i remember watching
you in my living room as a very very
young kid on the screen in awes not just
in that 2003 moment but but long before
then and when i think about when i sit
here with guests that are athletes or
successful entrepreneurs or whatever
they might be
they sometimes but not usually can give
me a sort of a fairly accurate
description of what happened in the
earlier phases of life that would would
mold them to become that champion or
that ceo that they later were you're
someone that is incredibly self-aware so
i was very much looking forward to
asking you the same question which is
when you reflect on the early stages of
your life what were the like defining
um molding experiences for better or for
worse that you would point at and say
that's probably why
or at least that led to in part who i
became later in life
um
i think
the best way of answering that would be
to say that
in my younger days i'm very young
without any
any kind of
triggering
events
certainly not that i can um
remember or ever ever sort of come into
contact with
i had enormous passion
and
some kind of
adeptness
for bulls skills
so if i had a ball in my hand
things just made sense i could work out
i could i could
in my sort of head i could have a
some some sort of target some sort of
goal something to do with that ball and
i could
i could work it out
that was part of the intelligence i had
was just
i could bring those things about
relatively effortlessly
and i had a real passion for exploring
that it still is the case with me i
still find myself
playing basketball and
and often so much of this i'll do on my
own
because it's my relationship with that
inner capacity i have
that interests me not to show what i can
do but it's that sense of i guess being
at home
and that's where a huge amount of the
revelations that i have in life come
from from that kind of relationship
however there was also another
relationship which again without the
triggering
event um
i grew up with an immense sense of
doom and fear about everything so i had
this incredible sort of passion and
inclination towards
expressing myself with with balls and
skills and
and in competition as well but the
competition side
was a need
that wasn't a desire the the the
achievement um all that stuff was
obsessive
um
but from a negative perspective because
i had this sense of doom surrounding
everything
that was my disconnect if you like i saw
other people handling situations that
seemed so simple to them but for me
insurmountable and yet when they looked
at me with regards to ah you know with a
ball in my hand what they thought was
impossible for me just was relatively
straightforward and i think those two
sides of my path meant that
i had this
constant uh
drive to just
find myself in a garden with a ball in
my hand that's all all hours of the day
and night most of the time
it's all i talk about all i talked about
what i spoke about all i did and yet on
the other hand i had this ever-present
fear that i built this
if you like
defense mechanism coping strategy
but ultimately identity
around how to
somehow
survive that fear and that that
for me that mechanism i put in place was
i had to
achieve i had to be perfect
and i had to
i guess ultimately take on the suffering
and and live that kind
of martyr savior
stroke
warrior archetype and as such i found
myself
really really uncomfortable
with when things were seemingly going
well it just yeah i found that
horrendously difficult to handle as a
result i would revert to that defense
mechanism of creating problems
if there weren't so i was constantly
looking in a state of kind of survival
for where the next problem was because i
was convinced with this ever-present
sense of fear that there was a threat
and it was there and so yeah those two
paths essentially
weaved in and out with each other
throughout my entire life but there was
no doubt that my ability on the field at
times to be in that zone was where i
felt my genius but at the same time
the other strength i had was that for me
it was do or die on the field so
therefore where other people kind of
called it quits and threw in the towel
i didn't have the choice
yeah the fear didn't just drop off and
let me just sit down for a bit so i
could go and go and go and go
when you talked about your childhood
there you said
despite there being a traumatic event
that had created this kind of
perspective you had about
um
this sort of fear but also this sense of
real peace and homelessness you
described it when you have a ball yeah
um
your dad phil was a a rugby player and a
football player uh cricket cricket chris
yeah yeah rugby and cricket yeah it was
just two things okay what was his
influence on you because it's you know
when i when i read that he was also a
sports player in his own right um
that's kind of typically the story you
expect to hear i sat here with eddie
hearn as well his dad worked in the same
business i've sat here with ceos their
dad worked in the same business and the
interesting thing i i
connected and i'm not making any
assumptions here so i'm asking the
question is
in the case of eddie in the case of um
uma kamani who was at boohoo
they describe a very similar thing a
real sense of kind of almost innate
feeling of pressure to succeed
and they also at times couldn't
necessarily tell you where it comes from
what did you either of your parents play
a role in that in that perceived sense
of pressure to succeed
no
i sort of like i said
i'm heavily into the introspective
side of all this and and part of that
kind of
search now for potential is is where
that's moved it used to be
grabbing the external and trying to
expand physically you know what more can
i have what more can how can more people
know my name or everything that could
almost
expand my reach and and
presence on a physical level now no
really no longer interests me it's it's
how to allow
my presence you know in that
non-physical space
um
and my
sort of
journey of looking into that has meant
you know i've i've questioned everything
and yeah my
my upbringing was
was you know fantastic in terms of that
you know and
uh
i had every opportunity to go and
do what i wanted to do um
i have my brother there as well
and my parents all sporty
but
there was just something in me which had
latched on yeah and this is something i
feel maybe it's something i brought with
me into this world from a you know like
a karmic positioning whereby
i was always going to grab things that
way i was i was susceptible to
understanding things a certain way um
but for me you know i i
i sort of pushed my parents hard yeah i
can't imagine it was easy my brother too
and the way that i was
i was sort of i challenged them in ways
you know i didn't give up
and a lot of that like i said was well
all of the
the irrational stuff came from the need
for them it was baffling but you know
they had their lives and i appreciate
that
as is always the case that
people are always doing their best and
that's what i remember about our family
the most is that everyone's always doing
their best and i look at everyone now
and realize that
you know people are where they're
supposed to be and just
giving it their all and and what's been
so so powerful for me is just being able
to
switch that interest with what giving my
best means is more than
unlocking and letting go and shedding
than a
what more can i grab and and you know
where that path turned around is perhaps
where you know where i felt
the the true understanding of of what
this journey's been about as opposed to
where i was looking to where did it come
from what happened here et cetera et
cetera it's more of a kind of uh it was
just about that you said something there
which some people might skip over which
is you said it might have been something
you inherited karmically or you know and
that reminded me of something i'd heard
you say previously about
being able to sort of inherit
generational
messages or um whatever that might be do
you believe in that do you believe that
we're passing messages from one
generation to another within within
ourselves and that that is shaping our
lives
yeah i believe that the
the role of karma is basically a memory
and it's that kind of
it's it's the way we've remembered
things and whilst
for me example for example when i'm
stuck in that really physical
identification of this is who i am
as in on me i'm johnny and then i do
have a start to my story in an end
but as i've been
sort of exploring letting go a bit more
of that
that kind of physical identity of right
now
i just tend to feel that it opens up a
different understanding of memory you
know
if we're a process of that evolution
then the cells in our body have a memory
that goes back a long way
yeah and
that's impossible to separate you know
where we come from from parents and
where they from their parents from their
parents from their parents you know
everything is all interconnected
but we put a stop and a start on it and
it seems yeah one of the things i find
so so interesting when looking at that
is that
i'm very interested in the science side
of it too and looking at
the desire of science to find
you know what it is that we're made of
and yet they keep coming up with it's
nothing and then they go to well what is
it we're living in
and they keep finding out that it's
unending
and yet who we are we seem to manage to
say despite the fact it's made of
nothing and it's unending we found a way
of saying but we're made of this we
start here and we stop there it just
doesn't make sense to me anymore whereas
before you know you live in those
boundaries
what you see
inherits those boundaries and i think as
i've released those you start to
not so much question but just allow
for different understandings to take
hold and one of those is that
that you know i find it fascinating to
look at yeah i've got a young child and
i find it fascinating to look at
children enter and they're all so
different
how are they so different
and then you say oh well
yeah it's it might be to do with how
their parents have behaved during the
during the the sort of um
you know the the months preceding the
birth and
yes but
even then
why are the parents behaving that way
goes on and on and it just goes back to
the same way that i still believe that
we're all doing our best
but there's a part which we bring with
us into this into this space and you
know i feel like there is there is
nature and there's there's that nurture
side but that nature yeah but that
that nurturing has been going on forever
and it's and it's important that we have
a bias and a
stance
because without it
i don't think you can have this physical
experience
unless there's something holding you in
it
and i think that's the point is to find
out what that is and
and engage with it embrace it and enjoy
it
and what is holding you within this
physical experience what is your stance
it's
so so interesting that question you know
at the beginning i'd have said um
oh you know this what i'm telling you
about my
fear
and then i'm talking about my need to
survive and then unlocking that and
going beyond it and you think i
understand it and you get challenged
again oh where did that come from i
think i understand that now and i feel
so much challenged again where do these
challenges keep coming from
and i think that's the
the part of me understanding what my
stance is is an ongoing process
an ongoing process of just enjoying
challenge and embracing it
i think i
use the kind of
expression when i talk to some of the
guys i i train
with and and the when they're they're
doing their sort of kicking with the the
rugby
is that it's all about sort of finding
that absolute piece and an inner
environment that allows you to go and
explore
this opportunity you've got ahead of you
and every time you find you you can't
find that state
it's because you're holding on to
something it's never because you don't
know something or because you haven't
learned something it's because
you're holding on to something you don't
need
and you have sessions right at the end
of it people are feeling like i feel
amazing and you're kind of thinking yeah
great just wait till tomorrow
because this idea is tomorrow
i'll still feel amazing but then the
next day you're how do you feel i don't
know i just feel a bit like this why
it's because each of those sessions that
we're doing it's like a light that
shines into your your garage where you
think you've cleared out all the bags in
your garage that you don't need anymore
and then you think that's all clear and
then a slightly brighter light comes in
the next day and you're like oh there's
loads of stuff over there i didn't see
that i better go and clear that now that
the more you clear the more space you
find in there
but to think you're going to get to the
end of that
for me to think i'm going to sort of
find out why i'm here
what i think i'm going to find out is
it's my choice to be here and that's the
beautiful part is the proactive reason
for being here
as we said in the question it was like
what's holding you here i think now
probably the the way i really see that
is is what's my calling what's my
purpose when that's fulfilled
uh that'll be an interesting moment but
i don't see that being anytime soon
it's really interesting reframing of the
situation because we you're right we
spend our lives looking for some kind of
external
given reason for us are in existence but
flipping that and saying
well yeah i'm choosing to be here and
i'm choosing to be here because of the
purpose that i've decided on um
it's a really powerful thing because you
know i mean
in my dms and messages i get from kids
it's this kind of outside external
search for this easter egg that they
were born to find called their passion
and their purpose yeah and when they
can't find the singular easter egg
somewhere they fall into such tremendous
like frustration and feelings of
inadequacy i haven't found my purpose
that means i'm a piece of [ __ ] and you
know that kind of that spiral downwards
one of the things you
you touched on there was um
the feeling of peace and you you know
and then
the um and also
just before that um you talked about
letting go of um
something because we're holding on to
something and that thing often is
identity and expectation something i've
definitely done in my life is held too
much onto a sense of identity and that's
really caused me lots of problems as i
read through your story starting from
your very early days in newcastle to
later it became apparent that you were
you're holding more and more onto this
expectation and identity which you'd
earned from your accomplishment
and that was having a detrimental impact
on your peace
yeah so talk to me about identity and
the journey you've been on there um i
think
for me
perhaps overriding understanding and it
comes i think from a lot of the way i
doubt my sort of immature days of
trying to understand that fear and what
was going to
transcend it what was going to help me
transcend it and that understanding was
i'll solve it
and when i solve it
this fear
machine
will suddenly turn into a joy machine my
suffering is going to result in joy
interestingly enough
by
feeding that fear with all the
reassurance whether it be hours and
hours and hours upon of kicking or
training that's telling me you know
giving me the greatest guarantee i could
possibly hope for which was no guarantee
at all never did anything but
it never sort of fulfilled itself
satisfied itself but that was the best i
could do
to try and reassure the fear of that
moment would say look i can do it you
don't have to worry i can do it
but of course as soon as i stop doing it
the fear comes back and says can you
really do it better do another one and
so trying to solve it
by feeding reassurance to a fear machine
the fear machine just becomes a bigger
fear machine that needs more reassurance
to get the same hit
trying to get that that same hit just
meant more and more reassurance so
you're building i was building greater
habits and needs to keep suffering
so i could keep solving so you lock
yourself into that cycle
and
that cycle
when you're locked into it
compared to when you're not
that's the only difference between why
you speak about expectation and fear of
failure and pressure is just because
you're in the cycle it's not a reality
to life it's the reality to the cycle
certainly to my cycle
and when i'm outside of that when i'm
feeling good for example in the middle
of the game where you're you're in the
zone if you could articulate anything in
that
sort of
mind space
you know what's the pressure like in
there
what are you talking about
how can there be a pressure to now when
you're in the now
there's no consequences to the now
because it's now there's no then or
before or after
so you can't have consequences you can't
have pressure
it's now and so
deeply understanding that versus the
cycle
i guess was where i realized what i was
trying to do with all this identity was
answer something
was answer a problem the identity was
creating the problem and the identity
was about solving the problem
i had to keep the problem to keep the
identity and i had to keep trying
solving it to keep the identity as well
and it was never going to go anywhere
and i think my big
issue with all that was i was trying to
answer something i was trying to find as
we said before in a world made of
nothing universe made it nothing that's
that's ever ongoing i was trying to find
that answer
and that answer for me was
from a an identity perspective was about
working stuff out logically
and yet all my peace and my joy came
from when my mind was
being
i guess
inspired by my heart
i spent most of my time trying to
almost uh i guess
inform my heart through my head
it was what i trying to do i wasn't
listening to that one moment where i
felt
beautiful
and then learning from that i was
learning from the 99 where i was feeling
so stressed and suffering and i was
using that as my guide i was using my
head as my guide and i think
the undoubtedly the the change in me has
been
to let go of the need to find an answer
to have that trust in that there is not
going to be an answer
there is going to be
um an ev expanding beautiful journey
which when you remove the answer it's no
longer a journey because it's not going
anywhere it's an adventure
and then that's what the now feels like
to me i think you know for me that
identity
was a massive relative
existence on a social level
how did i measure up how did i compare
all of that to do with trying to answer
that problem basically
to have this fear i'm somehow not worthy
or deserving of having what i want how i
want it
and therefore i've got to manipulate it
by looking for what's going to get in
the way of it and how can i control that
to see if i can get some of it anyway
instead of that feeling when you're in
the now which is
this universe
is working for me
and we're friends we're not yeah we're
not trying to
enter into some kind of
tricky sort of
i don't know shady deal
where you know we're both trying to con
each other it's like no no we're we're
in this together so mike is there some
game where one of you can win and the
other one yeah yeah it was yeah for me
that was always the guess why you could
never rest easy because
something went well that was the time to
be like oh you know
this is where
your life might have lost out because
i'm doing well so life's not gonna how's
life gonna come back and get me because
i've just tricked life you know i've
gotten something out of it and it's now
like i was gonna want repayment for this
and you're gonna get injured or
something you're gonna get injured or
you're gonna and i guess in a way when
you pride yourself on that perfectionism
and the achievements and the
which achievements basically also comes
down to how other people see you feel
about you what they think of you
and
when you sort of
yeah when you enter into to that kind of
space
it's uh you know
humiliation is perhaps
the biggest fall
you know that's the one when you pride
yourself so much on being perfect
the thing that scares the
the hell out of you i think on from a
physical perspective it's living and
dying on an identity level it's
humiliation
and yeah that was at the basis of a lot
of the training was it would be so
humiliating for me and the more
well-known you become the greater the
opportunity of humiliation when you're
the unknown it's kind of like it doesn't
matter too much you know when you're
playing down at the park and you miss
one no one's watching you kind of like i
can handle that but you know 80 000
people millions on tv when everyone
knows you and they're all thinking don't
worry he's got this
yeah that's the moment your
your battle with
you know fear perfectionism whatever you
want to call it ultimately led to an
obsession on the training ground right
because you describe that obsession on
the training ground is actually a
distraction from the fear that like
really never worked in terms of filling
the void um i i sat here as you were
saying that i said
if
johnny at
16 17 18 or before
had the mindset
you have now
would he ever become the player he went
on to become like if a 16 year old who
is very similar to johnny is listening
to this right now and he takes on all
the advice that you're giving about
being present and you know removing the
fear and living without expectation etc
and living in the now um
would that increase or reduce his
chances of becoming
world cup champion
yeah it's a it's a good one
and
in some ways i'd have answered that
quite simply by saying
it was when i was at my best
that i was already doing this
so in 1718 when i was on the field in
the zone i was
operating at a level i couldn't even
understand
and that's because i i was having the
mindset that i'm
talking about now right so i was already
having it and it was in those moments
that i really shone
so it's not like i never had it it's
just that when i did have it in those
years
i knew i was onto something
it's just the relationship i had was
that in order to
to get in the zone i need to suffer like
mad and the more i sort of like started
succeeding and feeling a bit of the zone
the more i said i better suffer some
more the more suffering the more zone
but of course you just overload the
suffering and you've got no room left
for anything now and i think
working with guys now is the best way to
answer this is that
i'm kind of
answering that question by working with
people
in that younger space
and
one thing that's certainly
yeah it's actually very it's impossible
to do anyway but it's it's also not the
right idea is to remove too much of
someone's suffering because you remove
growth so when i say suffering probably
challenges is a better word you know
obviously we don't want anyone to suffer
but if you remove too much of the
challenge you remove the opportunity for
growth so in a way
i was going to have challenge then in
whatever form
and i needed challenge i needed just
like saying if you keep winning
all the time you just see a plateau in
your performance
and so i didn't want people to agree
with me all the time i didn't want to be
written about in the paper as being the
best all the time as much as asked me
before the game i'd have said please
just let me know everything's perfect
but actually looking back
those challenges those moments of
conflict
it's what asks you to step up and go
again so i needed the challenge i needed
all that suffering
but it's just where it crosses the line
and becomes
counterintuitive and and
counterproductive
there needs to be
an understanding of how to
relate to the challenge so that you
don't face the same one over and over
again i think that's what i would
i would have been interested to see was
you know if you'd have gained some
ground on that challenge then what other
challenge would have come not that would
have been it but it would have been a
different route to see
um but it's largely irrelevant it's not
something i ever think about because
it's got
what i've been through and
and what i've experienced in that way
doesn't make me anything
you know the past doesn't make the now
the now is the now
um and i think you know who i am
is how i relate to that now and if i'm
carrying around this big idea of how i
got here and what i've understood i'm
just
separating myself from the now
and that's so big if i come into the now
saying here i'm bringing a past in can i
get in the door they're now saying no no
that key doesn't fit
you can't bring the past in here
you have to choose you're going to live
you're going to live
sort of
disconnected from the now and you can
have your past
or if you're going to allow that and and
have a different relationship with that
then you can have more of me you can
have more of the now i think that's uh
the same goes with the future you know
the more you carry your past the more
you you're carrying your future at the
same time but that same same principle
applies you know if you really want the
now it's a case of well you've got to
align with it and ask the now you know
what's the now trying to do nothing what
are you trying to do something okay well
there's the disconnect and i think
that's been huge in those moments on i
always come back to that moment on the
field when i'm in the zone
your identity's gone
you you there's no it's me doing this
it's me trying to do this there's just
doing
as this happened with the 2003 drop goal
it's the one moment that i can say
genuinely
um
it was happening without me involved
i was able to embrace it and enjoy it
and experience it but there was no me
trying to do it
it happened whilst i was in it
but it wasn't me doing it
is that
alluding to the fact that you were in a
flow state in that moment
yeah i mean whatever flow state means to
to anyone it's basically
that kind of understanding
i guess that there was
for me what felt like a
very very
immediate
relationship between what i was desiring
and intending on the inside
and the manifestation of it
was almost instantaneous
as opposed to the way people look at it
which is like i've got my goals and
and over time you know they're gonna
come together to form this it was
it was almost kind of instantaneous in
that respect
and that's that's where that sense of
past and future disappeared because it
was
inside outside
were
you lost their separation
was your mental health um
better or worse after that moment
um
i think it was a
a sort of
catalyst for maybe a
a deepening or intensifying or an
acceleration of what was already in
place
definitely
but it wasn't
a brand new thing
it was just a bit of a a deeper
i guess experience of it it came for
better or for worse for um well i mean
guess depending on how you look at the
challenge it was a
for example the emptiness
was just a bit more severe because
winning the world cup was the main goal
so
winning
the game
and the six the other the grand slam or
or getting selected for this or that
were huge goals
and the little parts of emptiness
afterwards that came
um
were was a bit less because
one it wasn't the main goal and two also
because it wasn't the main goal the net
the main goal was still in place which
meant you were therefore still moving
towards something
i think because the main goal
was so important but also afterwards
there wasn't that clarity of where i go
next yeah that was a bit of a deeper
drop into that space of what's this all
about and how does that feel in detail
that you describe it as a deeper drop
just just a a sense of confusion and
sort of bewilderment with the idea that
there was a promise here
there was a promise albeit one i've made
to myself but it's such a deep such a
strong one
and a well-defined one that said it's
gonna happen
i've worked hard for this i've done all
i was asked i've done all i asked myself
to do
again i keep sort of you know
i can't abide by the idea that you know
that there is this somehow this external
i used to use the blame and the
sort of offset that responsibility and
hand it over to something on the outside
to say oh yeah that's why i'm feeling
this way but now you know it all comes
from the inside but even so
that promise felt strong it felt real it
felt
um
and that you feel a bit sort of
cheated but also confused because
there is no one to blame there is
nothing to grab there's nothing tangible
that says the other stood there saying
you know well yeah i got you there
tonight it's like
where now what now and then there's also
a little bit of that extra confusion to
say well what's the point of the next
one the promise was that you'd receive
some kind of euphoric joy yeah and
fulfillment and
yeah it is the hollywood
ending
but of course hollywood films have that
privilege of
the credits coming up and
and leaves you with your imagination and
your imagination it always just
it's not in detail but you just think
wow how great for them but of course
should that camera carry on for even
another hour
you get you get stomach in there and
yeah that's all it took after the world
cup final you know
we went to a private party and you start
thinking oh we'll go there and have a
chance to chat that's going to be great
when you get there it's
oh these people you know that this isn't
private why they're letting you know i
can't even get here to see there's no
space you know it's already in
it's going and
but i think yeah
waking up the next morning's a big one
that night's sleep
you know leaves you in the cold light of
day
when it's all you know you're looking
sort of at the the room and the hotel
and it's a it's it's just as is
and it's it's not shining you know said
this before a few times i've spoken
there aren't people waiting outside the
door willing to you know hoist you on
their shoulders and carry down to
breakfast where you've got your own
special table it just
it is but it's so powerfully
kind of beautiful in that way in the way
that it allows you to
at some point understand that
there's also a really great reason for
why you feel that way because it's just
it's a it's a pointer to
there's a disconnect here
it's nothing to do with what's going on
the outside it's just there's a
misunderstanding here
and
an opportunity but that opportunity as
you said how do you move on to the next
one
it involves some vulnerability because
you can't walk in the shoes of the same
identity
but head in that other direction the
identity is the direction you're heading
in
you need
you know
a new identity a more spacious one a
more open one but that's vulnerability
that's you know to to do that you have
to
shed those
those
solid lines you've drawn up which have
kept you
safe and given you your
your standoutness
to others they can see you because
you're drawing yourself in solid lines
you can say this is who i am and you
talk about yourself in that way and it
feels like that's purpose and that's
that's kind of meaning and worth
but it's it's asking you to let that go
and that's humiliation as we're talking
about it's a humbling journey
and it's vulnerability and i wasn't
ready for it at that time definitely not
what also didn't help was the the game
after that i first played after that for
my club was two weeks later and in that
game
i crossed the line on a neck injury it'd
been building for a long long time over
years and in that game it probably
went and i spent the next couple of
months without being able to move my arm
and then
surgery and all this talk about you may
never come back and of course you've
gone from
this is what i do this is who i am to i
don't really know what's going on
anymore and now i can't even do what i
do so i can't even be those solid lines
i can't present anymore now i'm watching
other people do it so
it's an amazing
coming together
of circumstance to really point you and
say hey
what do you think should we have a look
at something else
that's like nah so i was i was on the
exercise bike the day after my neck
operation
with a neck brace on my brother came in
and saw me we were living together saw
me and sort of said what are you doing
and it's the need i've got to get back
to where i was and this is such a
powerful
thought is that
we want growth you want progress you
want to advance and to explore and find
new things and yet
the way i was going to do that was going
back
that's how i was going to find new stuff
i have to get back to who i was and how
i was
and yet deep inside me what i wanted was
and what i began my journey was i want
to find out what i'm capable of what i
was actually saying in this moment was
i want to go back to what i've had
to where i've been
that was a big big moment i just wasn't
quite ready to listen to it and as soon
as you do get back which i did for a
little bit before getting injured again
and again and again which was the stress
of all that that need and obsession
it's enough
because just enough of the old habits
and the triggers come in with people
around you saying oh you're doing great
so good to have you back in it
i'm back
but of course
it just it's just enough to hold you off
making that
that step in the other direction
and uh yeah that came about later on
i i resonate so much with that and my my
moment of i guess which is analogous to
your moment of being injured and being
trying to be back on the bike was when i
resigned from my company i kind of
looked at it and fell into the belief
that if i spend the rest of my life
living out these labels that i've earned
through my accomplishments social media
ceo or like entrepreneur or whatever um
i would likely end up abandoning my true
self and probably end up in like some
kind of mid-life crisis so at that point
as i write about my book my objective
became okay if i had no labels who would
who would i be and trying to really live
a life free from my confining identity
and be free to be the full expression of
myself
is the journey i find myself in now is
that what you mean when you say um
you were trying to get to the point of
understanding um
all you can be
is that what you're describing there
i i think what comes to mind when you're
saying that
for me was and it's also another way of
looking at the identity thing i think
you're speaking about is that
the more i've released those
boundaries of identity the more creative
i've become
and there's nothing more creative than
being in that zone as i say when those
boundaries are gone you're so creative
that you suddenly see things
and you put you join dots together in
ways that you can't imagine they could
ever have been and yet it's so easy it's
so effortless creativity is an
is an effortless
kind of capacity that we have it's not
one that needs trying to be involved
when you're becoming creative you don't
try to be creative that's the whole
point of not being creative is you allow
and you explore and what comes out
is surely more of what's really who we
are
and i think the thing for me and
that was that as a child i had that i
had that creative ability
and what i did was i embraced and i
celebrated
my creativity
as i got older what i did was i held on
to my creation and that was another way
of saying identity
so as i began to attach myself to what
it was i was creating instead of
exploring the creativity and the process
there i formed the identity because it
was the identity is look at what i
create you can't have an identity as a
creator because then it's still look at
what i create i'm a creator but to have
no identity i think in that respect to
be nothing on the inside as they say is
to be everything on the outside
allows you to to create and therefore
such a real interesting moniker or
marker rather for me is
how creative
do i feel right now
and to set the
environmental conditions internally
for creativity
effortlessness relaxation
excitement passion and ultimately
on the spiritual level
worthiness
and i think that you know when i say
about for me
that's been where it's changed because
you you can't be fully creative
and insist upon
the creation how it's going to turn out
and needing that guarantee that's
control
i'm going to be so creative as long as
it turns out like this
so you're not going to allow it to go
anywhere new you're not creating
anything you're almost you've got a
blueprint you're you're organizing
and i didn't after a while i think i
realized i didn't want to organize and
manage my talent i wanted to celebrate
it and like you said be all you can be i
want to see where it can go i want to
and all i can be means going beyond
identity the best i can be means within
my identity
the best ever is within a very small
identity
you want to be the best ever that's a
very small identity and you went through
those three phases right you write about
the first phase was you wanted to be the
best ever then you wanted to be the
second one was your best i can be the
best you can be and the third is you
want to be which is where you find
yourself now all you can do yeah it just
determines the strength of the idea or
opinion behind it i want to be the best
ever is a very strong idea this is there
are some game right yeah yeah and that's
hugely massive comparison massive
competition massive measuring up massive
dependence upon other people's views
yeah how do you know you're the best
ever because someone says i do right i'm
going to work on you i'm not going to
work on myself i'm going to work on your
opinion
um the second one the best i can be is
is an idea still what's my best well i
was good then so it needs to be that but
a bit more okay it's still a strong idea
you're still limiting yourself all i can
be
is looking at the eye
not looking at the rugby player
you know because the best i can be is
okay i'm gonna be the best father i'm
gonna be the best and these are all
great pursuits but they still don't
match up to what about
just
this being
how how
how much can i be in terms of how can i
explore my being
the best i can be still
just shifts over to doing
the best ever is all about doing
it's all about physicality best i can be
a bit less all i can be drops the
physical and that's where creativity
comes in you know being creative
physically means moving stuff around
being creative which is effort but being
really creative means you can sit
and just be
and that's where i think all the all the
opportunities
quick one as the seasons have begun to
change so has my diet and um
right now i'm just going to be
completely honest with you i'm starting
to think a lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 percent
of the time so i track it with 10 of my
friends in a whatsapp group and this
tracker online that we all use together
we call it fitness blockchain and i'm
currently at 81 percent
um so 81 of the days i've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so i'm going
to the gym about six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivatio live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
there'll be people listening to this
that are you know they left university
they went to school and now they're a
lawyer and they've been a lawyer for 15
years or they might be i don't know a
dentist now they've been a dentist for
20 years and
a lot of the time when i speak to these
people there's this other voice inside
them that's been suppressed over time
which is probably all they can be and
they've got really consumed in this
identity which they're like parents
wanted them to adopt of being a doctor
or a lawyer whatever it might be
um
it when i speak to these people they are
seemingly trapped by something and um
that that force that's trapping them
seems to be so much stronger than the
other voice which is which they
sometimes can even point to as being a
more fulfilling life which is i guess
all they can be they want to go and be
an artist they speak to me before my
show they show me their instagram and
they're the most unbelievable artist
i've ever seen in my life and they their
face lights up when they talk about that
thing but when i ask them what they do
they say yeah i work in the city i work
in finance for like kpmg or something
and you can see the dread in their face
how does someone start the journey and i
think you alluded to vulnerability there
but how does someone start the journey
of going from that place
of you know confinement and identity and
i am this thing that i've earned through
my achievements to being all i can be in
a practical way what's how does that
change
i think that voice that inner calling as
you just said is is passion and
excitement
versus the duty and the need and the
fulfilling the the roles
if you like of society and i think
therefore
for me the way that works is that
you you add to the passion excitement
constantly and allow that to look after
your deepest intention which is always i
want to spend i think
all my time fully present which means
doing what i love doing
being who i feel like i'm meant to be as
much as that will keep evolving and
changing so therefore it comes down to
following your highest passion and
excitement in every moment
and people might argue straight away
well how can i do that if i've got to be
at work at
seven in the morning and i've got to do
this and i've got to go and traipse
across town to get here yes but within
the boundaries of what you have to do
what's your highest excitement follow
that so you know i've got to drive
across here and it's going to take me
two hours and
but then when you're in the car
tune in to what's my highest passion
excitement i love this podcast okay go
that's it i really want to listen i've
got that my
hands free i'm going to phone so-and-so
because i just thought of them and i
really want to chat to them follow that
intuitive instinctive impulsive side
that comes from
what you want
and
when that gains momentum
i think
the way it works is that
the universe responds by providing more
and more opportunities to do more and
more of what you like so that you your
highest impassioned excitement
the environment allows for you to really
do more and more what you really love
doing but you've got to start the ball
rolling by saying right within this
moment right now
how can i what's my highest passion
excitement
how can i be
how can i bring more of me
into this as opposed to allow this to
take away more of me
and i think that
is a journey that just
looks after itself you know it's on a
physical level it's the do what you the
little things you can do set goals and
allow them to you know what you focus on
what you can do and allow it to expand
and
and
grow into the most amazing things
it's the same way of just doing that on
an internal level it's just follow your
heart and it might be physical it might
just be things i love thinking about
it's it even if it comes down to
to being you know you're you're stuck in
a lift and you're kind of like and it's
a tiny lift and you're going to be there
for maybe for a while
okay but
people talk about going to a happy place
but that's what's my highest passionate
excitement oh what i love to be doing
now paint it
picture it think of it dream it feel it
all those kind of things all these
things are amazing things to be doing
and if you're following your highest
passion if you're enjoying and embracing
this moment i spoke to someone recently
saying that
you know to know you're on track for
your future manifestations of your
dreams
the indicator is often how deeply are
you embracing and enjoying this moment
now
and once you find yourself loving this
moment it's amazing how much things just
fall into place for you
and i think that's the key to is to be
able to say whatever it is whatever you
can do
do it
and bring it to this and i think
that voice that says oh i can't do this
i can't do that it's not possible i
shouldn't do this or it's not right is
another way of saying
i i can't be me
it's so interesting because when you
were saying that i was thinking about
the former version of myself at 18
living in manchester and most side where
you know i i was very very i had nothing
and i was shoplifting as i've talked
about a million times food to feed
myself but in that moment i was although
i was working in call centers at night
night shifts i was so unbelievably
excited by life because i was also
designing my website in my designing my
future business in my lunch time in my
breaks of that call center
um
and
people i've said this for years and i
don't think people believed me but i
i've said i was as happy then as i am
now that kid was so optimistic and so
happy even though he was he had no money
and he was working night shifts in a
call center um and i appea and it sounds
so privileged like obviously because of
money now whatever but um
it resonated with so much of you are
saying then i think it's because of what
you were saying then was i was still
pursuing my highest passion despite the
fact that i was working in this call
center i was not occupying all of my
time and my thoughts that i could with
that future and that's what i believe
manifested me being here because i could
have made the decision
um
that this was my destination and my
forever and i'd probably still be there
now now in most side yeah i i definitely
agree
the idea about following your highest
passion
there is a passion i think deep down is
for expressing
who you are and there's no doubt for me
that rugby for that period of my life
was what i was meant to do that's how i
was supposed to play out that was
that was what i was supposed to be at
that time
um
but then your passion changes slightly
and to be able to
leave the rugby and follow that passion
often i think people say you know it's
really difficult to find my next passion
but i think
having that
that kind of ability to to leave behind
what's been
is what allows passion for what can be
and i think like we were saying before
about wanting to you finish your rugby
and then you think i'll go straight into
coaching because it's close enough and
people still know me and i thought but
actually to have that period of
not just after an end of a career but
daily to have that quiet period every
day where you just sit not with
not with ideas i'm going to think about
this or i need to plan this or i need to
work out what my passion is but just sit
and just disconnect
from that pull of the external eyes
closed and just watch but of course away
comes in as am i doing this right
what should be happening should i be
feeling something i haven't had any
ideas it's been two weeks and but just
do it
just do it in in the name of moving to
your potential
because we were so willing to
to give to our limits look at how many
years we spend suffering and telling
ourselves certain things that have come
from old ideas that no longer serve us
we're willing to give all our time to
those
but people are still alive it's too hard
to find 10 minutes to
sit on an evening what am i going to do
when actually you know you have that
moment where you're sat watching
something on tv and it's not really
interesting and you're kind of like
that's time there but once that ball
gets rolling when your passion centers
around something and everything comes
out of that same passion so it's all
aligned it's all kind of focused energy
that's gonna manifest there's no doubt
you know like i'm sure at some level
there's no way you get to where you are
now without there being
that drive now i had that
in the rugby
and a lot of it was
a sort of conflict and it stressed them
out of me but it was so damn strong
that it had to win
because i wouldn't let it not win i just
didn't do it in a way that was enjoyable
same
and now i think when you release the
conflict you get even more flow you get
an effortless version of what i've done
through efforting
i've efforted heavily yeah i heard that
word recently i really like it i much
prefer it than tried or given so much
but
i've really made it
a sort of
an effort version of how to get to the
top and what that means is when i look
back it's like how was it i never smelt
the roses that's what most people say
yeah because there's another way to do
it
and maybe that's how this has come out
for you versus the first i don't know
you know like these projects for me the
next things i'm doing seem to just kind
of
oh yeah there it is that's interesting
whereas before it was oh god
get out of there don't you dare whatever
it is
i think that just comes from at some
point just saying well okay this is what
i've got
acceptance
and then
what do i want to do right now what's my
next step responsibility
and you can't get to that passion
without the acceptance and the
acceptance is
this is what i've got this is where i'm
meant to be this is how things are
and once i come to ease with that then
suddenly there is that well i can start
to feel what it is i want to do next
yeah but while there's that resistance
to this it shouldn't be this way and
should i be doing this or i'm elsewhere
future past
passion and excitement are kind of like
look whilst you're trying to survive
we're not relevant to you
you know someone in survival isn't
really interested in passion excitement
and i was in survival most of my career
hence why i keep saying about my career
you know the passion and excitement died
away not because i lost
i fell out of love with rugby at all not
at all just purely that i was in
survival mode more and more and more and
the more i went into it the less
relevant
creativity growth love
connection with teammates excitement
passion joy it's just not relevant to
that
you nailed it when you described me as
well with that when you said um the
drive that i had that was really strong
was actually upon reflection just deep
insecurity yeah still a big drive there
it's still a big driving drive hard to
shake when you think about winning the
world cup and you said that was the goal
was that really your your
goal
yeah it's in i think having
later that insecurity is often for me
just comes down to the opposite of trust
it's distrust
in yourself or whatever but when there's
a different trust about it
that acceptance i'm speaking about
is all-encompassing
that it
it when you accept now
it is a full acceptance of all that's
been
now is is yeah if you accept this then
everything from a physical perspective
that's brought to here also sort of is
accepted
and
therefore
for me
it was my goal because deep down my
inner calling was i want to be free i
want to be happy
and i i want this and so
according to the energy i was in
these were the cooperative components
when a world cup why so you can see that
that's not quite where you need to be
going
all right have some injuries why so you
can go through your own learning at the
speed that you're choosing
you can't go any faster than you're
ready for you can't go any slower
it is simply as it is and as you explore
i think
it kind of as you start to expand it the
expansion takes place i think quicker
once you get going i think more
revelations come and it kind of opens up
harder
or faster but the the point for me being
that
that trust is just
it may have taken
40 years
to get to this point from a but from an
experiential level
i don't feel 40 years has gone into this
it's been instantaneous
because it's just memory it's not 40
years
so i kind of love the idea of
people confusing the past with memory
when it's memory and you start to
realize its memory and you start to
realize that you have a
say in the emotional
involvement in that memory you can
release it from those memories
that you can play with your past
whereas people have a fixed idea of past
and yet they want a different future
it's like like a railroad track
you know that has a certain piece that's
slightly curved and the train is going
along and reaches back from the previous
piece and sticks in front because these
are my understandings about how life is
this is how it's going to be and so you
end up just going round and round and
round in circles instead of the classic
cycle breaker
which is
that random different piece and
sometimes it's a big shock or a trauma
for people the way you kind of get a
piece that's like completely different
direction suddenly you head off into the
unknown and people have those amazing
experiences but sometimes it's just a
piece which is slightly
less curved
and that's what those moments were for
me you know that different understanding
of like hold on i thought there was
going to be joy here i was convinced
there isn't and suddenly that cycle
break in your thinking just enough to
change the piece a bit and you head here
and you widen your circle and eventually
you start to be in control a little bit
more of
how you're going to see each event so
you can start to best you can shape
those pieces to send you into the
unknown
which is why i didn't want to go before
you know that's the
the the unknown was the threat the
unknown was the was the potential slip
up we're talking about was that kind of
shady space where you're not in control
anymore whereas now the unknown is like
well if you want potential you want to
see what life is
it's unknown and the more unknown you
see yourself the more you align with
life less ideas i have the more unknown
i am the more i align with life the more
that i start to
to get that
that's i think that more instantaneous
response we're talking about instead of
it taking 40 years
you know for me it's kind of over that
40 years it's been
sort of
expanding out but over the last
15 it's been quicker over the last five
much quicker and over the last
one
much much quicker
this
the
vulnerability is an interesting word
because it assumes it makes you feel a
certain way but this this truth and this
openness that you speak
um
which is kind of marks the way you speak
now this kind of i'm willing to tell you
all about myself in terms of how i feel
and what i'm thinking
and i'm willing
again this is an assumption i don't care
as much about what you think of me based
on what i'm sharing now whether it's
about your mental health or about how
you're feeling which again are things
that men don't typically do especially
you know leaders in sport right
what impact has stepping into your truth
and being open and like free from
caring too much about what others might
think of you because you're so open
about your mental health and other
things what impact has that had on your
life
i think it's the openness is is
is not
um
a conscious
decision i'm not coming in saying i'm
now going to be so open about it the
same way that i might have been
unconsciously closed before you know
still kind of not speaking about stuff
not because i'm sitting there thinking
i'm not talking about this but because
that feeling says this is where i want
to stay within the boundaries of this on
the conversation
and
now the boundaries are wider not because
it's not now a narrow boundary of all i
ever talk about is how my suffering is
kind of like but
you talk about
i guess what's relevant to the moment to
the conversation
and it's inspired rather than
um
pre-planned
i like i said to you before i think i
used to be a big one for preparation
um
so coming into this you know i tried to
think what i'd have been like when i was
21 but i'd i'd have been you know out
there with with my sort of agent or with
my my dad or my mum or something and
i've been waiting to come in and be like
yeah and they'd be like it's going to go
fine don't worry it's going to go fine
but yeah it is just make sure you i'm
going to talk about that and i might
talk about that story if you ask me
about that
it's planned
on the basis of i'm trying to achieve an
outcome from this
but
when it become which again is that whole
kind of like
what i create what i actually create
defines who i am so what i'm going to
create from this will define who i am so
i need to make sure it's how i want it
to be
all based on this idea of who i am but
without the idea
i think
i speak
according to the
situation not according to my
identity and i listen according to
what's maybe more of what's really being
meant than what's being said and again
it it's this
i guess it's this different
more
less solid
idea of who you are that just suddenly
opens up the understanding of what
really listening is and being there is i
mean being there for someone is such a
amazing phrase when you really look at
it to be there for someone
it means fully being
now if you people are saying about how
what's the best thing to do if someone's
struggling is like just be there for
them okay but you mean like just
physically stand there
and be loving and but all if all of this
is an effort it's designed
to get an outcome
but it's to get an outcome for someone
else you must have to know what's right
for them
and now you're deciding
and limiting them but if you want to be
all you can be you you can allow others
to be all they can be you can allow a
situation to be all it can be
and i think that kind of for me has been
you know the the
one of the biggest
openings and an example i'd say was i
spoke to a young
football player a while back
maybe sort of
15 16 years old and someone said would
you mind just having a
chat
and i said yeah of course i'd love to
you know you get that inspirational sort
of feel immediately that yeah this is
one of those
cooperative
manifested moments of there's something
that i've i've called for
and this has been
offered and i think i'm going to explore
this you know because it feels right
that it's in my path
and we had a chat and
midway through the chat it came to me in
quite a sort of
emotionally sort of
i guess intense way
i suddenly realized that
i wasn't talking to this person
as if i was
40 they were 15.
as if they were a young soccer player i
was an ex-rugby player
i suddenly realized that i was
exchanging on a level here where
it was energy form to energy form
not age
relevant at all not even
defined simply that
i was performing a role of serving
and being served at the same time
according to
allowing and letting it be whereas
before it would have been okay right
before the call you kind of put on your
mentor shirt you know going to be a
mentor now and um you know
but a talk like this and give it the
whole kind of yeah well i guess if
you're going to play sport you know all
this son of stuff but instead you phone
up and
suddenly i realized i'd lost that idea
of
the difference between people and people
talk about it from you know age gender
all these kind of things you know
religion race everything and you sort of
think
we're all trying to do that
by listening to the right thing to do
and what people should say and how you
should speak but it's all the answers
are
in your own journey
to releasing all your
sort of self-discriminations and
judgments
that then it just becomes so easy and
obvious but so joyful and such a
a true exchange according to what's
really being asked for rather than two
people playing a game on the surface of
playing our roles and seeing what we can
get from each other
it's two people sharing what's really
being asked for
and i sort of feel like if you like for
me from that perspective that's the
first time i've
i've kind of understood what it is to
really care for someone
is to completely let go of
your own ideas
of them and in order to do that you have
to
let go of yours about you
and i think that's the selfless side of
it it's funny that expression you know
it's selfless you remove yourself and
you can be selfless
and just being able to sit there and
listen and be fascinated by someone
has been a really i think a big big
moment in that and that that kind of
yeah it's been a
that's been a nice change that moment
for me was one where i suddenly realized
you know that i've been playing a game
for so long according again to that
identity what i need from this how it's
going to look
you know i i'm using people i don't mean
necessarily on on that whole kind of
exploitative
you know i guess in a way it is but
you're kind of using them to get them to
feel a certain way about you
you're using them to
to say what you need them to say for you
to fill that space and once that goes
relationships i think take on a whole
new level
interesting you're essentially using
them to confirm the the identity to fill
the whole yeah makes me feel like i'm
your mentor yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
so you know i need at the end of it i
need you i need that kind of like thanks
so much for your time yeah i can't
believe you're doing this and i need
that backup call that comes when the
person introduced you says oh they're
over the moon they're so chuffed you
spoke to you've changed your life
forever
you need that because that's what i'm
yeah because without that am i doing a
good job
but once that goes is to be like but i'm
doing
what i was supposed to be doing
when i when i look over your story one
of the the threads that goes through it
even up until today because i i read
that you were thinking over in the
process of starting a mental foundation
is the story of mental health something
that has become a greater discussed
topic in our generation specifically
around because there's a lot of men that
are arriving at the unfortunate decision
that the only way out is to to end their
lives and it's the now the big biggest
single killer of men under the age of 45
in our country
your mental health journey um
twists and turns it seems i remember
vividly reading that you you're in your
hotel room and you're playing days
looking at the tv and it's basically
just lights because your head is
overthinking at an unbelievable rate and
it sounds it sounds somewhat and i'm not
familiar with
the medical definition of a panic attack
or anxiety but it sounds somewhat like
that um have you ever experienced
depression in your life
about a period where
and again i'm i'm not a doctor but where
you feel a sustained low
and that would be clinically described
as depression yeah but they'll always go
together
yeah because for me they do
because you have that sense of panic and
anxiety
um
which for me has always been around
sort of finding these
these insurmountable issues throughout
my life what seems to be the
insurmountable which is basically saying
according to how i've
positioned my view of life
this is now insurmountable according to
my belief system this means this is an
issue and we can't pass each other
and
the fear then kicks in
the lack of control the the panic kicks
in which again that hysterical nature of
it
you know it tells me that it's you know
it's not rational to the to the moment
you know i don't talk about there's no
threat here but if i'm having that
threat i know it's it's coming from
something deeper but the fact that it's
insurmountable the fact or it appears so
and the fact that before i wouldn't have
seen changing your energy
otherwise known as changing your
identity i guess in a way or removing
your identity i wouldn't have seen that
as an opportunity so therefore you're
stuck in that insurmountable space
and that's where the depression kicks in
what's the point
what's the point this is me now
i can't live with i can't live without
this i'm stuck the needle is right in
the middle and every time i
try and move it one way to get some
clarity
once it goes that way i panic it has to
come back i don't want it to go that way
so i bring it to the middle and then i
try and work it the other way and it's
like i don't want it to go that way
and it's this
classic two voices you mentioned
which is this call for
happiness
and this call for joy and and freedom
and all that the stuff which just
blossoms out over and over again in ways
that beyond belief
but another voice that says i don't want
that
i want it so much and i don't want it at
the same time and the don't want it
voices
the ident this is who i am i think i am
and i want to save this whilst having
that those are the two voices
and
when you're locked into that i want to
save this
i want that becomes i can never have it
this is all i've got and right now
if this is me
you know
what's the point but
understanding for me that those two it's
those two voices
that i'm working with not
external truths
you know external situations and and
they're not this is the way the world is
and unfortunately therefore this is ways
that's the voice that comes from old
ideas
and understanding you're working with
old ideas and old ideas represent that
energy state or shape it that when you
start to realize well hold on on an
energy level if i just trust i keep
working with my energy and i trust as
long as it takes
i'm gonna work on it
that's it without this idea that
you know this idea of how and when it
should sort itself out well you know i
heard that person talking about getting
some revelations and i haven't had any
yet but i should have any some after two
weeks
oh it hasn't been i'm not getting any i
can't even you know it's like no just
leave it open-ended and
you know if people go to the gym
sometimes when they don't really want to
it's kind of like well
why not just sit quietly for 10 minutes
when you don't really want to but just
do it anyway
just do it and just say okay
i'll see it's a bit like the
they're looking in the mirror when
you're going to the gym you know over
day after day you don't see it someone
else says hi yeah what's happening there
you kind of i've been going to the gym
it's like all right i haven't really
seen it it's the same as sitting quietly
it feels like nothing's happening but
it is
quick one as we all know energy
independence and living a little greener
has never been more important for a
better future it's a journey i've been
on over the last couple of years that
i've shared with you sporadically ever
since i sold my range rover sport and
bought an electric bicycle and there's a
lot of people out there that listen to
this podcast that are looking to make
that sustainable switch in
the things that run their daily life
whether it's their home their car their
vehicles whatever it might be so when a
good friend of mine at a company called
my energy called jordan told me she was
interested in sponsoring this podcast i
jumped at the opportunity so for those
of you that don't know my energy are a
uk renewable energy brand whose mission
is to increase the usage of green energy
helping people like you and i to save
time and money when it comes to making
sustainable switches in our lives so if
this resonates with you and you're the
type of person that's been looking or
thinking about going on your own
sustainability journey i highly
recommend checking them out at
myenergy.com
patrice everest here
manchester united football legend left
back um
and he
said that one of the questions that
really changed his life was one day when
his girlfriend turned to him and said
patrice are you happy
and when he was asked that question and
i remember when i was asked that
question because my girlfriend at the
time
asked me when i was driving home in my
car back to my house after work and she
turned to me and said are you happy and
it was it made me feel uncomfortable
okay and patrice described a similar
thing like he kind of snapped back at
her of course i'm happy but then she
persisted and this kind of was a really
a real turning point in his life where
he eventually admitted to
to being molested when he was in school
something he'd never told anybody and he
couldn't have never confronted and that
set him off on the journey of
understanding himself in truth and
finding
a way to not be this tough guy anymore
and to be compassionate and loving and
to be all he could be right um
are you happy
it's a
i was just thinking that whilst you were
i presumed you were gonna
i took the long way around that yeah
i think
i think happiness
when you're asked it that way is is a
bit of a destination yes or no isn't it
it's like a yes or no it's kind of like
you know what
i
like to see it maybe in terms of
am i
grateful to be alive
and i think yeah am i full of gratitude
is my way of looking at it
am i
um
am i in touch with that
that sense of
of just being
yes so
so pleased that i'm i'm having this
opportunity of life and yeah
definitely
and i wonder sometimes even in my
darkest moments if you kind of go
you know this is part of that journey
as well and in a way when i look back
it's more so much more difficult at the
time i mean
almost impossible when i look back am i
pleased and grateful for that it's like
yes i am because it always turns out
that it's the answer to a deeper
connection
and i feel like yes am i happy
i'm grateful
to be alive
and i don't want to change a thing
and i think that's kind of for me would
i change anything i don't want and i
think that's a sign you know
i feel like as was underneath so much of
the
the the rugby stuff the achievement
stuff the
savior stuff the warrior stuff the
mata stuff it was always a case of
i'm not enough so i need to earn it from
other people
from outcomes from life or whatever and
i think that question is
are you happy is like
do you realize
you know that you're enough do you feel
that you're worthy and deserving of
being here and i think that's the
connection to
to everything
and i think maybe that's the answer all
this energy change stuff we're talking
about or
or old ideas or it's really comes down
to recognizing
that
you know are you are you aware of just
how well you are that this whole
universe is
is answering to you with these
experiences
you know the whatever's happened
this morning and whatever's happened on
my journey here and meeting you it's all
been put in my path
for me
the same way it is for everyone it's
like i miss
i heard another expression a while back
saying that um
we're so important with that
without you the universe couldn't be all
that it could be it would just be some
of what it
could be
and and therefore it couldn't exist
that's how important we all are we're
here because we're supposed to be here
and what's great is that you know that
finding out your your passion your your
your joy and your true minis is not
something you need to worry about just
something you need to allow out
and know that all these events are
pointing you i think pointing us all
towards all we can be
if we're willing to listen but when we
answer them try and stop them we're
basically saying no no i've found who
i'm
supposed to be and therefore i don't
need this
but when i think we're willing to
to look at what we've been given and say
well i must need this
and maybe there's something asking for
this
deeper that knows way more than i do
so you know i'll step out the way for a
bit
and have a good old listen
shelley
your wife yep
what role has she played and
just having a partner through this this
journey
what role is that played in
you discovering and going on the journey
of
becoming all you can be
i think it must be the same i don't know
for for all people i did hear eckhart
tolle say that
relationships
were the spiritual work for the west
you know it's for these
i don't know what the case is now but
yeah maybe it used to be sitting on
hillsides but
people sort of think i can't i can't do
that because i've got my
responsibilities but it's like this is
the work
relationships are massive like that
and you know she's perfect in
in every way because she's perfect as
she is
um but
also
because she's
she's exactly what i need
and that means when
i get challenged i'm kind of like this
is what i need
and
it's yeah like i said it's it's
when someone sort of provides that
opportunity for you to
to sort of
be more of you
on every level i think that's
that's kind of gold dust and therefore i
think you know i turn up and i don't
expect or
or think she should be or any certain
way
um i need her to be exactly as she wants
to be and is
because it's right for me and hopefully
i'm being the same for her but
um it's funny how we both
kind of growing in our own ways in our
own directions
i think because of each other and now
you know we've got someone else on that
journey with us in our little world and
and exactly the same relationship
i think the best thing is both of us
neither of us are trying to
lead a change in the other
we're both trying to sort of uncover
more about ourselves and that's doing
everything in the working relationship
as i said before you know working on
someone else really doesn't work for
anyone but working on yourself tends to
work for everyone
and i know you have a uh
is it's like a kombucha-style drink
right it's like uh what do they call
those they call them so it's a living
drink feminine yeah
it's number one living it's called one
living yeah and uh it's uh yeah it's a
kombucha string we've got water kefirs
which more fermented drinks we've got
all kinds of
stuff on the on the uh on the market
around yeah i was curious about that
because i'd seen this shift in your
perspective of diet and nutrition
throughout your life and i wondered if
there was any advice
for for me based on the journey you've
been on again this is maybe a bit
selfish for me to ask but i know there's
other people who would think it because
again when i was a young i guess i still
am a young man but i was very much just
smashing well i still am smashing
protein shakes trying to build my
muscles and i'm really focusing on
trying to have like a really good
looking body yeah whereas what you've
said is that health is much more
important and when i read that that
you'd made this distinction between
health and fitness i kind of looked at
it and i thought to myself what does he
mean because i thought kind of health
and fitness was almost a similar thing
yeah i think
for start my brother's a fitness
conditioner we played together
professionally
up in the north and then um
you know his his side has always been
the the fitness conditioning side so we
have a really close relationship on that
and he's exploring loads of this stuff
my wife was trained to become a
nutritionist um so she was exploring all
kinds of things in the the natural
sort of healing side of nutrition but
also in nutrition
as a whole and i was looking massively
into the mental emotional side of it so
we all kind of crossed paths my wife and
i especially on kombucha uh
and different cafes we started making
them at home we were putting you know
going blackberry picking putting them in
a real kind of shift compared to being
in a changing room and unwrapping these
kind of foil covered laboratory based
their bars have been constructed and
and i think that was the difference for
me is that
i spent my life
being very fit but not really that
healthy
and fitness is
an interesting one i think everyone kind
of realizes this to a degree is that
when aspirationally you you really push
itself down a specific
route physically
to adapt to be able to do a certain
thing
very very sort of fully you
you kind of
you distance yourself slightly from the
hole if you it's a bit like sort of a
mountain as you climb top more more to
the mountain it gets a bit more isolated
up there
and i think
health is about what fitness can come
out of unless you look after health
it's dangerous it's a dangerous balance
i think to take you know you have to
look after health and then explore what
your fitness can be rather than go after
fitness thinking it's going to lead to
health
it it doesn't you know the
i work on this with my brother as well
and in the um
in the stuff we we do with regard to the
foundation we we speak about stuff and
one of the
the areas we talk about is
life fitness which is another way of
talking about health which is about that
effortless flowing capacity
to be so graceful in what you need to do
every day and not you know talking about
the aspirational side you might see look
i can bench press this and i can lift
this look at the state of me look i've
got no body fat and this but it's kind
of like okay let's see you get in and
out of your car
you're like okay now
what we're talking about here is a life
fitness which has some balance in it now
don't get me wrong i was one of those
guys that was
rugby wise i couldn't bend down
the idea that i would sort of have to
look under the sofa for something i'd be
like i'm gonna have to live like take me
about three minutes to get down and five
to get back up
but
there's a
real
grace to that balance
and if and you know you talk about
strong men and and maybe a story of the
past but where strong men
which told if you carry on like this you
know
this effort to become the world's
strongest man your life expectancy is
probably not going to be much more than
45
and
people yeah okay i'll take that
because of the
the the the ambition the drive behind
what's behind that which is absolutely
up to absolutely everyone but for me
having finished rugby i i think i
understood just
how far i'd ventured from health and
and the living drink side with the
number one living stuff we do is is
around the connected nature of
yeah we're more bacteria than we are
cells
and yet
yeah we also live in a world where
there's a great deal of sterility at the
moment so bacteria are kind of
disappearing we're not getting outside
so much digging our hands in the dirt um
on top of that
um as antibiotics have found their way
into all kinds of
different foods um and so you know we're
finding ourselves short of these things
and what they're finding out is that
bacteria has a role in connecting the
body
in ways we don't even know is that
incredible and we're made of mostly of
it
um and the the balance between all these
kind of bacteria and even viruses and
all kinds of things that going on us is
imperative to our intelligence and how
we operate
so that's been effort behind that but
also trying to help us shift back
towards health so that we have this kind
of
genius
way of living our life
so that we can involve ourselves fully
in every moment rather than have that
kind of oh i've got to do that
but it's fine because i'll go into the
gym after but you know washing the
dishes is a good one
i use as a metaphor an idea for i once
got asked by athlete triathlete
um about i was speaking to triathlete
and i said you know
but you love doing a triathlon but you
don't like washing the dishes but what's
the deal with when you wash the dishes
what are you trying to do
i'm just
trying to wash the dishes or what are
you trying to do when you're doing
triathlon well i'm sort of
i've got a goal and i'm
working move my body to get through that
to achieve a certain goal what are you
doing when you're washing the dishes
well there's a goal and i'm working my
body through it to get to a goal it's
the same thing but there's an
understanding that this i like and this
i don't
this i'm willing to do this i'm
unwilling to do
this i'm
willing to be joyful about and this
therefore i've decided already is not
but to bring that kind of
whole engagement to every moment is
health
when you have certain things which are
great and others which aren't that
involvement now involvement or lack of
involvement is is for me is what fitness
was you know as a rugby player training
brilliant brilliant gym matches great
going for walks yeah not bad
sitting around
sitting quietly no chance
you know getting in and out of the car
like i said terrible
no way you know all these kind of things
and yet people say i wish i'd made more
of my life wish i'd enjoyed every moment
but that starts with health health of
physical mental
emotional
and exploring that and that first of all
comes with
you know exploring
the body and you know the classic would
be
we sit now maybe sometimes for so long
that we
become very good at sitting
aspirationally we've become great
sitters the same way we've become great
rugby players or
whatever it is so our bodies are
starting to shape towards that
and they're forgetting
everything we knew before
and now you find sometimes the best
feeling you can get is by just
stretching your arms back and going oh
that feels nice
i've forgotten how nice that was yoga
yeah exactly the danger is is that
we end up in a few years
where we've lost it
and it's to remind yourself that is
health whereas if you're doing one thing
the whole time
without reminding yourself of everything
you can do
um everything you as we speak about
identity wise you become so obsessed
with
being this kind of person you forget
that you're everything yeah but i'm
being this something but you've got to
keep reminding yourself that you're
everything otherwise you're going to
lose your grounding and you're going to
get lost in the small
and losing yeah you're going to get lost
in the wave
and you're going to lose sort of you
your your
homeliness in the deep sea where it's
all peace and you're you're every wave
but as it is you know we're in that
individual
thing and health and fitness is part of
that movement and
health is about
what you eat what you drink how you eat
how you drink how you breathe how you
move sleep recovery restfulness peace
it's it's an endless journey
i think people think that health and
what have you is about
not being overweight
trying not to perish of anything before
your time
um but you know and maybe hang on to
being able to do some stuff when you're
still
reasonably young it's health is an
endless journey
of just unending discovery
or
if it's related to fitness it's
looking good for others and feeling
attractive and
and having to eat stuff that you don't
like tastes horrible and wishing you
could have this
and you know and getting to bed you know
after as long as it's not too late after
you finish your netflix series or
whatever
johnny um a truly remarkable
conversation and it really highlights to
me uh i was thinking that this guy
should have a podcast and i reminded
myself that you've just launched your
podcast which is called i am yeah and i
also now understand why it's called i am
just from this conversation
you know it's funny because i listened
to some of your podcast episodes before
you sat down and um you're interviewing
people i don't know why i'm saying this
to you but
when i was listening to it and i just
thought i don't know why i said but i
feel compelled to say this i was
i wanted you to talk more
yeah because of everything i've
discovered from this conversation today
and you're someone that's gone on a very
introspective journey who has managed to
pull up those
um pieces of the train track and send
them in a
uncertain direction which most people
haven't and you're discovering a lot on
that journey which i think is so
unbelievably valuable so when i listen
to your podcast i am i just wanted more
of johnny um but it was a it's a really
really brilliant podcast for i mean i
didn't need to i don't even need to just
explain why having listened to this
conversation today um
but yeah i just i've absolutely loved
loved this conversation and uh
you talk about a lot of the things that
i as a very kind of introspective person
talk about people think we're weird
right
yeah you do get that sometimes i think
the best thing to be
seen at the moment with the way that
society leans i think it's quite
powerful to be seen as
illogical
in your responses
because everything's leaning towards
stress and and winning and conquering
and achieving and
and the reactivity and our stress has
become a marker in workplaces you know
the more stressed you are the more
important you must be and it's almost
like worn as a badge you know kind of
like check me out i'm i'm pushing it
you know i i might not be sort of
my future life
is uncertain because i'm really willing
to to sort of give so much to this
whereas to be seen as illogical
and a bit irrational in that area
um
it's quite a strong
place to be right now because of where
we are so you know when you're kind of
i've said this before we used to have
games rugby games where we'd lose
and i'd be sat there
head down in the change room
you know trying to run
this kind of thoughts through my head of
like oh how you know it was against me
it never works out and i've got to come
back stronger and you know what a wasted
opportunity i'll never get this back and
i'm a you know what a failure etc etc
what's this going to mean for me
and then you see someone looking in the
mirror putting their tie on he's already
had a shower already out there tie on
and they're sort of like where are we
off to tonight lads
and of course society's voice or the
changing room's voice or the team's
voices how dare you
how dare you be thinking about how good
life can be
how dare you respond according to your
dreams
and the life you wish to live come and
react according to the life that we want
you to live can we react according to
the life that you should be living one
way you sit here and show how much you
care and how disappointed you are
whereas in fact now when i look back i'm
kind of i wish i'd been
looking in that mirror with that guy you
know i wish i'd been out there earlier
saying yeah well you know what
i gave everything the learning's taking
place i don't need to sit here and and
torture myself with this the learning
has taken place because i've got some
gay great contrast i wanted this i got
this it's only refined my view
immediately of what what i want now even
more and it's given me some
understandings of of what's working and
what's not the fact that i'm going to
think about them isn't going to change
those i've got them the question is as
we said
how
the marker of whether they're on their
way depends upon how much i'm enjoying
this moment and what do i want to be
doing now i want to be out with the guys
or i want to be at home with my family
but instead i'm going to sit in the
chamber i'm going to be last to leave
and i'm not even going to go in the
shower until
the the ground's turning the lights off
in the clubhouse i mean i'm going to be
last out to show you guys that i care
and i'm hurting the most
and it didn't mean a thing you know as
far as i'm concerned you know like i
said it was part of a lesson i had to
learn but
i i think
being seen as
irrational in that way
as long as it's according to the life
you wish to live and it's not about not
caring totally different things you know
it's a beautiful space to be in i think
and you know what a what a beautiful
place to end i am again this is why i'm
so excited that you're now a podcaster
as well and i'm really excited to watch
that journey play out and to see where
that that journey leads you because it's
you never know with podcasting as i
didn't i didn't know i'd be sat here
doing this now but
for many of the reasons you've described
about that kind of manifestation and
just kind of asking myself um to
to figure out who who i could become and
all that i am that's what's led me here
today and it's you know there's a real
serendipity to the fact that we're
having this conversation that's led me
to meet you so thank you so much for
your time thank you so much for being a
um a very open book in all regards
because it's a very healing thing for
many people who are yet to go on the
journey you've gone on we do have a
tradition on this podcast which is that
the last guest
asks the next
uh let's guest a question okay
um
and this is a very interesting one
because
i've read about your answer to this
previously but i can't say who the guest
is but their question for you all right
and they actually wrote a book about
this that's what i will tell you their
question to you is
what is your biggest
regret
um yeah good one i don't it's it's it's
a good i used to
spend all my time on these kind of
things when i was younger
and now i i just can't for the life of
me
i can't find a place for regret
it's understanding that
um for a start on a physical level if i
went back to wherever i was
as we've said before about other people
and inhabited that energy
i see the world the same straight away i
feel the way i do straight away i do
what i think what i think i do what i do
i create what i create
i can't do anything different it's
inevitable
the now which includes everything that's
come to the now it's inevitable
and to resist that
is to
and not accept that
is to continue reacting
into the future and i think
the continuing of reactivity
is what i'd regret now about my future i
don't regret anything that's been but i
think sitting here now i'd be like it'd
be a real shame if i just kept reacting
for the rest of my life
what i say is but how nice would it be
to
to let inspiration decide my future
rather than my
my regrets and all my old ideas and i
think we mentioned about
that train track regret for me as a
classic of reaching back and going
more of the same place
and just planting your own and you know
in that respect i think some
people kind of spiritual people do this
they look into people's futures and kind
of go let me just see how you are at the
moment right
if you have that going on i can pretty
much guarantee what you've got coming
yeah
but that's not what i want i want
surprise
and i can't have regrets and surprise i
can't have
that kind of looking back
i can't have such an idea about how it
should have been
and then have freedom in the future if i
want freedom in the future i've got to
free up the past and therefore you know
regret has to
has to take a bit of a sideline on the
bench
amen
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you